[Music]
I do my best work with quite a bit of
noise some music typically or some type
of cafe a restaurant environment I'll
give two one is the graveyard book by
Neil Gaiman fantastic fantastic fiction
book with an incredible narrator and
this is water by David Foster Wallace to
the commencement speech the book or
listen that has been most influential to
my own path I would say are the moral
letters to Luke ileus by Seneca the
younger I have read all those letters I
would say several dozen times what I
like most about storytelling the ability
to ride a wave of imagination to the
extent that I lose track of time I had
to pick one thing in fiction plot
character or setting I would choose
character I think that is the connective
tissue realistically I would probably
narrate my memoir just it's such a
specific genre of book it might be
strange to have someone else do it but
otherwise I would have to go with Neil
Gaiman even though I'm not British the
guy's voice is just so hypnotic and
incredible I write always for myself or
a few of my closest friends
I'm never writing for a general audience
if I had to define it as probably number
one it's a simple answer is
living in such a way that you like
yourself if I had to add to that I would
say it's probably some combination of
achieving what you want and also wanting
what you have least favorite sound is
any device at high volume on an airplane
but some kid is using because their
parents are parenting by negligence
little judgey answer figure we need one
of those
[Music]